WHEN THAT HAPPENS, WE ARE GOING
TO GO RIGHT TO IT.
FIRST, WASHINGTON'S REAL
MARCH MADNESS, THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE" ."
ALL RIGHT, WHEN MOST OF YOU HERE
TERMS SUCH AS OMNIBUS SPENDING
BILL, NO DOUBT YOUR EYES GLAZE
OVER, BUT THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED
TO KNOW, IT IS A LEGISLATIVE
SCAN BECAUSE IT INVOLVES
PACKAGING A LOT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S SMALLER SPENDING
BILLS INTO ONE GARGANTUAN BILL.
THEN THE WHOLE THING CAN BE
PASSED WITH ONLY A SINGLE VOTE
AND ONLY THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE.
SO LONG GONE ARE THE DAYS OF THE
SO-CALLED REGULAR ORDER WHEN
REGULATIONS WERE DONE THE
SENSIBLE WAY.
DEPARTMENT BY DEPARTMENT, A LOT
MORE TRANSPARENT THAT WAY.
EACH BILL BEING CONSIDERED
SEPARATELY.
UNDER THAT SCENARIO, CONGRESS
AND THE VOTERS WHO ELECTED THEM
HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
EITHER STRIP OUT THE WASTE AND
FUND ONLY ESSENTIAL PRIORITIES.
IT MAKES SENSE, RIGHT?
FOR YEARS, WE HAVE HEARD LEADERS
IN BOTH PARTIES PLEDGED TO
RETURN TO REGULAR ORDER, YET
NOTHING EVER HAPPENS, AND IT IS
BACKED TO THE MIND-NUMBING
CONTINUING RESOLUTIONS, OMNIBUS
NIGHTMARES, AND SHUTDOWN
THREATS, AND THE RESULT IS
USUALLY A LAST-MINUTE
BUDGET-BUSTING CRAMDOWN.
SURE ENOUGH, AS SPRING KICKS
OFF, HERE WE GO AGAIN, AND IT'S
REALLY UGLY.
DEMOCRATS ARE STILL IN THE
MINORITY.
THEY ARE BLAMING THE G.O.P.'S
POISON POOL PROVISION, AND, MIND
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISO
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISN
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISP
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISL
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POIS,
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISM
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISS
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POIST
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISR
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISP
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISB
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISI
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISA
YOU, WHAT DEMOCRATS CALL A POISS
CALL ESSENTIAL FOR LAW AND
ORDER.
>> THEY INSIST ON POISON PILLS.
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL GET SERIOUS
AND WE CAN GET THIS DONE BEFORE
IT IS THE 23RD OF MARCH.
>> THIS BUDGET HAD TO BE
FINISHED.
THEY WANTED TO ADD 160, 170
POISON PILL AMENDMENTS, NONE OF
WHICH WOULD EVER SURVIVE A VOTE
ON THEIR OWN ON THE FLOOR.
>> DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
HAVE WORKED TOGETHER TO REJECT
MANY OF THE POISON BILL      PIL
MANY OF THE POISON BILL      PIR
MANY OF THE POISON BILL      PID
MANY OF THE POISON BILL      PIS
MANY OF THE POISON BILL      PI.
>> Laura: MEANWHILE,
CONSERVATIVES ARE IN REVOLT,
BECAUSE -- BIG SHOCKER, IT
INCREASES SPENDING.
>> THIS IDEA THAT ALL THE BILLS
COME TOGETHER IN ONE BIG, WHAT
WE CALL AN OMNIBUS -- OMINOUS
MIGHT BE A BETTER WORD.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A TRILLION
PLUS DOLLAR DEFICIT PERHAPS
AS EARLY AS THIS OCTOBER WHEN
THE NUMBERS COME OUT.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS UNDER A
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATION.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER.
>> WE HAVE GOTTEN THIS BAD HABIT
OF THINKING MONEY HERE IS FREE.
IT FALLS FROM THE HEAVENS AND
MONEY IS FREE.
IT IS NOT.
>> Laura: I LOVE THAT.
THIS MEANS REPUBLICANS WILL
NEED, OF COURSE, DEMOCRATIC
VOTES TO PASS MY PAST MEASURES
IN BOTH CHAMBERS.
THIS MEANS MORE ADD-ONS, MORE
GIVEAWAYS, MORE JUNK.
IT IS A TOTAL MESS.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHAT TRUMP
PROMISED?
HE PROMISED TO CUT SPENDING, TO
DEFUND BOONDOGGLES, AND, YES, TO
DRAIN THE SWAMP.
>> WE WILL IMMEDIATELY TERMINATE
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S TWO ILLEGAL
EXECUTIVE AMNESTIES AND WHEN HE
DEFIED FEDERAL LAW AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WILL
CANCEL ALL FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
SANCTUARY CITIES.
WE WILL END ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
KEEP THE DRUGS FROM POURING INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO ALLOW THEM
TO ARE NOT GOING TO FUND AS LONG
AS WE HAVE THE ABORTION GOING ON
AT PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
>> Laura: BUT AS OF TONIGHT,
IT LOOKS LIKE THE STUFF THAT
SHOULD BE FUNDED BY THE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY WON'T BE
TOUCHED AT ALL.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, SANCTUARY
CITIES, OBAMA'S EXECUTIVE
AMNESTIES, AND THIS IS MY
FAVORITE, ALMOST A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR A TUNNEL CONNECTING
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY.
OH, IT IS A DISGUISED EARMARK
FOR CHUCK SCHUMER.
NICE GOING, CHUCK.
AND TWO OF THE MOST LIBERAL
STATES IN AMERICA BENEFIT.
AND THAT IS THE SHORT LIST.
IT PASSES FOR A LAW, THIS FREDDY
KRUEGER-LIKE OMNIBUS BILL WILL
INCLUDE OVER A TRILLION DOLLARS
IN SPENDING, $1.3 TRILLION.
AND IT WILL PASS WITH SCANT
DEBATE OR SCRUTINY.
MY FRIENDS, THIS IS JUST SHEER
MADNESS.
IT IS TIME TO STAND ON PRINCIPLE
WITHOUT FEAR OF A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
IT IS TIME TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT HOW BOTH PARTIES GOD
OFF-BOARD.
YES, YOU HAVE TO COMPROMISE IF
NECESSARY, BUT WITH FULL
TRANSPARENCY, AND, IF POSSIBLE,
NOT ON THE CORE ISSUES.
YOU ARE THE MAJORITY, AFTER ALL.
START REALLY HELPING
PRESIDENT TRUMP DRAIN THE SWAMP.
DON'T ADD TO IT.
YOU'LL DO THE COUNTRY GOOD AND